kinder kriegen meine damen und herren
ist schon lange nicht mehr das
selbstverständlichste der welt sondern
eine politische canzone in der schweiz
zb streitet man sich gerade darüber ob
frauen ihre eizellen spenden dürfen und
in polen und den usa
wenn man den zugang zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch erschweren
wir finden zeit für einen
philosophischen stammtisch zur frage wie
ihr kinder machen dürfen
herzlich willkommen und herzlich
willkommen auch meinen stammgästen wie
immer ist das katrin noack aus berlin
konrad paul liessmann aus wien und als
gast heute bei uns frau bettina schöne
seifert sie ist professorin an der
universität münster
sie ist philosophin und medizinerin ich
freue mich sehr dass sie hier sind
herzlich willkommen ihnen allen
ja frau schöne seifert das thema
abtreibung damit wollen wir beginnen ist
zurück auf der politischen agenda warum
ich glaube nicht weil die
philosophischen probleme neu sind
sondern aus unterschiedlichen gründen
politischen gründen trump in den usa ist
ein erklärter abtreibungsgegner in polen
sie haben das schon erwähnt sind
konservative restriktive politische
kräfte an der macht und dann gibt es
natürlich eine ganze reihe von neuen
fragen die damit zu tun haben ob man
kinder zukünftig kinder auswählen darf
und diese auswahlmöglichkeiten hängen an
den neuen techniken darauf werden wir
sicher spielt das haben sie gesagt also
sie glauben nicht dass philosophie star
jeden die jetzt großartige fragen noch
im raum sind ist das thema denn
philosophisch erledigt also erledigt in
dem sinne dass es eine zwingende antwort
gebe
gewiss nicht aber die frage die die
gretchenfrage in der ganzen abtreibung
nach dem moralischen status des embryos
spricht die von der frage was schulden
wir ungeborenem leben um seiner selbst
willen lebensschutz würde schutz
diese frage ist alt und lange diskutiert
und ich glaube auch dass die argumente
für die unterschiedlichen positionen
sehr gut auf dem tisch liegen
ausbuchstabiert sind
und dass es da nicht wirklich neue
kontroversen gibt eine position ist ja
sehr deutlich sehr klar die wird auch
vertreten nämlich abtreibung ist mord
und jemand der das vertrieb oder eine
organisation die das vertritt ist der
marsch für das leben eine organisation
die es weltweit gibt in der schweiz auch
sind die tätig die organisieren
kundgebungen wir sehen hier bilder aus
der schweiz
im januar hat in washington der 44 marx
for life stattgefunden
einer der hauptredner war
us-vizepräsident mike pence
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da kann man sich ja schon fragen warum
ist dieses thema offenbar so wichtig
dass der us vize präsident bei auftritt
alice ich kann es jetzt was diese dazu
ein usa betrifft nicht wirklich genau
einschätzen
das hat natürlich sicher auch mit dem
pedal starken vielleicht von religiösen
evangelikalen richtungen zu tun die hier
gerade bei den republikanern relativ
stark sind und die eben diese sehr
pointierte positionen vertreten wie
übrigens auch im prinzip die katholische
kirche das mit dem moment der empfängnis
an dieses entstehende leben in voll sind
der menschenrechte eben würde besitzt
und schützenswert ist und wenn ich diese
position vertreten ist natürlich
abtreibung wie es hier formuliert worden
ist ein unrecht und verstöße dagegen die
philosophischen debatten frau schöne
seifert hat er schon angedeutet sind
aber seit langem genau um diese frage
geführt worden
wann jetzt tatsächlich im
heranwachsenden leben der zeitpunkt
erreicht ist man davon sprechen kann
dass diese schutzwürdigkeit im vollen
sinn zutrifft es sich um eine person
handelt und man kann der
unterschiedlichste argumente findet die
versicherung für sehr sehr spannend sind
also ich vertrete er diese position als
medizinischer laie muss ich jetzt sagen
wie sie auch das von der queen vertreten
hat mag überraschend sein nehme ich das
mit dem zeitpunkt wie man das früher
nannte der beseelung heute würde man
sagen der empfindungsfähigkeit der
kognitiven wahrnehmungsfähigkeit des
embryos diese schutzwürdigkeit in kraft
tritt und das läge in etwa genau bei
diesen drei monaten die auch bei dem
legalisierten formen des
schwangerschaftsabbruchs in der regel
gegeben werden man kann aber darüber
hinaus natürlich der auffassung seien
dass der schwangerschaftsabbruch als
jetzt form der geburtenregelung denkbar
ist aber wahrscheinlich wirklichkeit in
zeiten wo wir ganz andere möglichkeiten
dafür haben und wird die optimalste form
darstellen seien jedoch noch kurz bei
dieser frage ab wann ist das leben
schützenswert nicht sehen dies auch
niemand
ich finde es wird ja oft konstruiert als
sozusagen eine art von konfliktsituation
zwischen den interessen der mutter und
den interessen des embryos also wenn
eine frau ab treiben will also sozusagen
die selbstbestimmung der frau im
kontrast zum menschenrecht des embryos
und da finde ich es natürlich insofern
ist tatsächlich so ist dass embryonen
beim jetzigen zeitpunkt der wissenschaft
ich weiß es gibt japanische
wissenschaftler die intensiv daran
arbeiten künstliche gebärmutter
herzustellen aber beim jetzigen zustand
kann nur eine frau ein weiblicher uterus
ein baby austragen und da würde ich
halte das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
frau doch recht hoch ansetzen
ich finde auch im prinzip was herr
wissmann gesagt hat also dass wenn man
anfängt sozusagen wirklich
empfindungsfähigkeit babys im bauch zu
haben die sich bewegen die sozusagen
schon menschlich sind dann wird es immer
schwieriger zu sagen man bricht jetzt ab
aber ich finde sozusagen diese ganz
frühen stadien wo zellen sich vereinigen
da sehe ich überhaupt nicht inwiefern
hier schon von einer menschenwürde
gesprochen werden könnte also diese
zwölf wochen haben einen sinn ich glaube
dass es im späteren stadium je mehr
menschen ähnliches wird desto
schwieriger wird und trotzdem würde ich
sagen ethisch würde ich immer noch dass
die gesundheit der mutter priorisieren
über der gesundheit des babys das würde
also da gibt es ja auch unterschiedlich
dass sich jedoch schon an einem anderen
punkt jetzt legen die schon ab wie sagen
so zu sagen es gibt da an
bestimmungsrecht der frau und dann gibt
es vielleicht auch noch irgendwelche
rechte von embryonen wie auch immer das
ist jetzt sehr flapsig formuliert aber
ich würde zuerst wirklich noch wissen
wollen was mit dieser schutzwürdigkeit
auch damit müssen wir auch wirklich
anfangen denn keiner würde sagen die
selbstbestimmung einer mutter die ein
einjähriges kind zu hause hat ist
vergleichbar mit ihrer selbstbestimmung
während der schwangerschaft und der
grund dafür ist dass wir das schutz und
würde recht eines geborenen menschen
eben alle die wir hier am den tisch
sitzen ganz anders einschätzen als als
das den moralischen status eben einer
befruchteten eizelle und genau das
sammeln die leute ziemlich um was fürs
leben dass das die falsche position ist
das symptom empfängnis zeitpunkt an
schützenswert ist das philosophisch auch
haus und position vertreten ist nicht
ihre oder es ist ganz gewissen ich meine
ich teile die position dass
empfindungsfähigkeit eine notwendige
voraussetzung für moralischen schutz ist
die und empfindungsfähigkeit meint
wirklich dass die die kreatur über die
wir reden ein sozusagen ein wie
empfinden hat und nicht dass es ein
schmerz reflex ausüben kann das kommt
viel früher und die die neuronalen die
gehirnstrukturen die dafür notwendig
sind so etwas wie bewusst sein was ja
dann voraussetzungen von
empfindungsfähigkeit ist zu haben kommen
nach heutigem wissen noch deutlich
später als im ersten drittel der
schwangerschaft zustand also das ist
wahrscheinlich wirklich als ausgereift
vor dem letzten drittel der
schwangerschaft so dass man daraufhin
hätten sich auch später aber noch ganz
kurz einem einsatz dazu die die position
dass schon eine befruchtete eizelle den
status eines geborenen menschen hat also
diese das motto dazu man lehrer die die
katholische kirche hat die ist deswegen
so absurd wenn auch nicht nachweisbar
falsch weil man inzwischen aus
naturwissenschaftlichen einsichten weiß
dass der unterschied zwischen einer
befruchteten eizelle und einer sagen der
hautzelle oder herzmuskelzellen einzig
und allein darin besteht in welchem
aktivierungs zustand die gene des kerns
sich befinden die sind sozusagen auf
embryonale oder auf
hautzellen gestellt und dass das den
unterschied zwischen vollen schutz und
gar nichts aus dem potenzial itc
argument kommen also kann man sagen aus
einer hautzelle wird eben haut und kein
mensch aus einer befruchteten eizelle
wird ein mensch das ist aber nur richtig
wenn man die natürlichen normal umstände
sozusagen als hintergrund mit ins spiel
bringt denn wir wissen heute dass man im
prinzip jede zelle sorte in eine andere
sozusagen um trägern kann und das heißt
eine art potenzial zweiten grades hat
auch nach hautzelle mit 1000 tricks dann
irgendwie so zu einer stammzelle zu
werden oder zu einer im prinzip eben
auch zu einer keimbahnzellen ich habe es
natürlich so dass häufig unglaublich
interessant wer aber das restliche
potenzial it2 kommentar tatsächlich
besagt dass er diese ist es nicht meine
position ja aber ich sehe schon auch
eine gewisse plausibilität darin zu
sagen wir kommen gewisser weise eines
teufels küche wenn wir die frage der
schutzwürdigkeit an sozusagen im bericht
beobachtbare tatsachen wie
empfindungsfähigkeit der
funktionsfähigkeit bewusstsein und
dergleichen mehr anknüpfen
denn was für den embryo gilt warum gilt
das nicht für erwachsenen menschen und
erwachsene aus welchen gründen auch
immer mal ins koma fiel der hat kein
bewusster hat keine empfindungsfähigkeit
ist er dann einfach tot basiert auf
menschen
das wäre etwas anderes im ort also ich
verstehe das problem ich schon die
dahinter stecken und die verstehe auch
sozusagen die stringenz des potenzials
argument auf der anderen seite haben sie
völlig recht dass potenzielle täter
argument in deren in dem diskussions
kontext funktioniert so nur wenn ich
gleichsam die natürlichkeit an dem
werden auf natürlichem wege wird das ein
befürchten erzähler unter normalen
umständen ein mensch auf technischem
wege wird es vielleicht bald möglich
sein dass beliebige zählen sozusagen
menschen oder organe hervor gehen zu
lassen
aber das enthebt dass er doch nicht da
probleme wie gehen wir damit um wenn es
sozusagen technisch gelingt aus einer
hautzelle sozusagen tatsächlichen
menschen zu klonen
ab welchem zeitpunkt der entwicklung
noch dazu wenn das vielleicht ein
wirklich in einem künstlichen
sie vollziehen kann an welchen zeitpunkt
entwickelt sein wandern jetzt dürfen
dann immer weiter gehen aber jetzt ist
der letzte zeitpunkt wo man noch
verdichten dürfen wenn mit dem versäumen
dann haben wir schon sehen die
möglichkeiten der in der zukunftsmusik
wenn wir dann gegen diesen technischen
uterus haben ich möchte mal konkret
machen an einem an einem beispiel an
einem wirklichen fall
es gibt einen finden der wurde gerade
vorhin gezeigt in der sternstunde
religion man kann auch online noch sehen
das ist ein film der heißt woche 23 die
entscheidung in diesem film geht es um
eine frau sie ist schwanger
in der 23 woche sie lebt in israel
zusammen mit ihrem mann und dieser mann
ist filmemacher und er dreht diesem film
dieses paar ist schwanger mit zwillingen
und es kommt in der woche 23
zu einer überstürzung der ereignisse
mein kleiner
das ist der schlimmste moment in meinem
leben
letzten donnerstag hatte ich eine
routinekontrolle und frau doktor klassik
machte einen ultraschall
schon bald war klar dass etwas nicht
stimmte
[Musik]
zuerst war nur einer von euch beiden zu
erkennen
nach einer weile entdeckte sie deinen
bruder so winzig zu klein
meine ärztin sagte uns wir sollten so
schnell wie möglich ins krankenhaus
gehen für mich ist es sehr hart zu
akzeptieren dass wir einen von euch
beiden verloren haben
nach einem abend voller trauer über den
tod seines bruders gingen wir am
nächsten tag ins krankenhaus
dort machten sie einen kopf ultraschall
und sagten sie könnten nicht garantieren
dass du gesund heißt
[Musik]
frauen ju max viele frauen machen
pränatale untersuchungen ultraschall
gehört bei uns zur routine
dann kann man auch weiter erstsemester
test machen bluttests man kann
irgendwelche biopsien machen
fruchtwasser funktionen ist das wirklich
immer hilfreich für die frauen wenn
jetzt das dilemma sehen mit denen diese
frau zu kämpfen habt ja das problem ist
tatsächlich bei diesen
routineuntersuchungen müssen muss man
sehr genau wissen was die konsequenz
wäre aus dem resultat bevor man sie
macht sonst sollte man sie nicht machen
dieser film zeigt er aber noch einen
viel schwierigeren fall wirklich ein
unerwartetes ereignis nämlich ein
zwilling stirbt und alle ärzte raten zur
abtreibung weil das risiko einfach sehr
hoch ist und dann kommt es zu diesen
konflikt ich finde der film beschreibt
den ganz wunderbar und der ist ja und
das ist ihnen ganz wichtig für dieses
thema was ihr heute diskutieren zutiefst
ein religiöser konflikt also was der
film zeigt ist er ein israelisch
schweizerisches paar also dass israel
die israelische familie ist säkular aber
hat diese jüdische tradition dass eben
abtreibung nicht wirklich so
problematisch ist dass der embryo auf
jeden fall das leben des embryos weniger
wert ist als das leben der mutter dass
das leben der mutter auf jeden fall
geschützt werden muss und dass auch ist
ein es gibt in israel eine sehr große
tendenz dass man versucht nur gesunde
kinder zu gebären und dann ist eben
diese schweizerin mit einem eher
religiösen christlichen hintergrund für
die es klar ist sie will auch das kind
gebären auch wenn es eine behinderung
haben sollte und ich finde bei kann
diese man sieht in diesen finden eben
sehr schön hier ist letztlich doch auch
so ganz alte religiöse
selbstverständlichkeiten sind also ob
ein kind eine gabe ein geschenk ist oder
ob man eben sozusagen entscheiden kann
was man welche art von hilfe mein leben
leben mutter seines behinderten sich
findet der film zeigt diesen konflikt
wunderbar der der soziale auftrag der
taucht eben genau deswegen auf weil es
eine entscheidende religiöse differenz
gibt es sind die entscheidende differenz
mit einem säkularen und einem religiösen
weltbild stimme hinzu aber ich glaube
dieser film den ich auch sehr
eindrucksvoll finde ist ein guter anlass
noch einmal sozusagen einen ordnungs
versuch in diese schwierige debatte zu
lancieren
ich glaube nach wie vor dass die die
eben angesprochene frage nach der
schutzwürdigkeit des embryos sozusagen
nadelöhr frage für alles ist was dann
kommt wer nämlich wirklich die position
vertritt aus religiösen gründen oder
philosophischen gründen oder bauchgefühl
dass schon die befruchtete eizelle an
vollen schutzstatus hat der kommt gar
nicht mehr in die situation so viel
abzuwägen in der stammzellforschung in
der frage ein behindertes kind auf die
welt zu bringen
in der frage gehen die beispiele aus
aber so sagt alles was
präimplantationsdiagnostik und so weiter
diese diese grundfrage aber in der wir
eben mit aristoteles geflirtet haben
diddy ist außerordentlich ernsthaft und
und eben wirklich nicht so leicht zu
beantworten und ich glaube auch wie
viele andere dass es hier eine reihe von
unterschiedlichen positionen geben kann
und auf dauer geben wird die einander
nicht dominieren werden in den
gesellschaftlichen debatten wir müssen
also lernen auszuhalten mit
unterschiedlichen positionen umzugehen
und das sind dann auch politisch
umgesetzt würden sich nicht sagen also
wenn man das was in den usa gerade
passiert also diese wenn man das bei der
stunde bei diesem diesem ereignis als
die schutzwürdigkeit das fahrzeug bei
der ton dann hat man sozusagen alle des
debatten über die wirklich schwierigen
philosophischen und medizinischen und
ethischen fragen wie man dann mit
verschiedenen technologien mit wichtigen
die möglichkeiten umgeht hat man einfach
ausgeschaltet und zwar vollkommen auf
kosten der frau und von dem her ist es
sozusagen eine position die das leben
ungemein vereinfacht fracht aber so
zeigt eine der wirklich interessanten
ethischen fragen mit denen wir uns doch
auseinander setzen müssen weil die
technologie sich einfach
weiterentwickelt mehr zulässt und es ist
ja kein zufall also in den usa läuft
eben der kulturkampf eben auch ganz
stark über so eine art von fragen nach
geschlechter ideologie und sollen wir
zurück zu frauen in europa aber da werde
ich doch gerne auch noch sozusagen die
andere feministische positionen
einbringen weil es gibt ja beide
feministische positionen gibt diejenige
die sagt mein bauch gehört mir wir
denken an alice schwarzer 70er jahre die
frauen gingen auf die straße um für ihre
das haben wir mal reproduktive
selbstbestimmung zu kämpfen
es gibt aber auch die feministinnen die
sagen dieses ganze
diskutiere rida über die frage was ist
die schutzwürdigkeit des embryos die
medikalisierung der schwangerschaft
diese vielen tests das alles setzt
frauen enorm unter druck weil frauen
würden das irgendwie eigentlich gerne
anders machen und frauen würden gerne
selber entscheiden können was möchten
sie wirklich getestet haben und sie
werden da hineingedrängt diese
feministische positionen gibt es auch
völlig richtig und ich stimme ja auch zu
dieser position nur man kann nicht die
frage nach dem der schutzwürdigkeit des
embryos unter den medica lisi russ
kontext schieben und sagen das wollen
wir eigentlich alles gar nicht haben
sondern man muss sich ihr stellen und
erst dann kann man eben alles schwarz
positionen haben die implizit da ist
nämlich ein embryo ist noch nicht in den
ersten wochen um seiner selbst willen
ein schutzwürdiger mensch sonst würde
keiner sagen können mein bauch gehört
mir
man kann eben auch nicht sagen mein haus
gehört mir und seinen siebenjährigen
rausschmeißen und deswegen muss man
diese frage auch wenn sie unbequem ist
diskutieren oder will ich nur noch mal
sagen aristoteles kann man eben mit
seinem potenzial itc argument nicht
loslösen von seiner metaphysik die
nämlich darin bestand dass er glaubte
die natur sei sozusagen schon so
geordnet dass alle dinge ihren zweck
ihren platz und ihre aufgabe haben und
da hat eben auch ein embryo die aufgabe
ein mensch zu werden während wir das
heute und dazu kam seine damals noch
sehr antiquierten vorstellungen von der
besiedlung also der in dem entstehen von
empfindungsfähigkeit und mehr am tag 60
bei weiblichen und einfach 40 bei
menschlichen embryonen das alles haben
wir inzwischen mit mit hilfe der band
ließen frühjahr bis sie richtig dachte
er damals und wir wissen heute dass das
was ihr seele genannt hat eben gar nicht
entstehen kann vor einem bestimmten
hälfte der schwangerschaft zweites
drittel der schwangerschaft zeitpunkt
das ist kein bio logistisches argument
sondern es ist das argument zu sagen da
muss eine bestimmte entwicklung erst mal
da gewesen sein bevor wir von so was nie
seele reden können
das ist die richter argumentieren wo das
problem darin besteht aber was mich an
diesem film interessiert hat um darauf
zurückzukommen ist dass er noch ganz ein
anderes problem aufwirft dass damit
natürlich zu tun hat nämlich bei dem
film geht es nicht um eine abwägung der
gesundheits der frau gegenüber das
lebensrecht des embryos die gesundheit
der frau ist nicht gefährdet
es geht nicht um die frage des lifestyle
das will ich jetzt ein kind haben oder
wirklich keines haben die frau will
diese zwillinge
es ist eine intakte familie das ist ein
wunschkind
sondern es geht um eine ganz andere
frage es geht nur prognose dass dieses
kind womöglich behindert auf die welt
kommen wird
und jetzt geht es um die frage soll ich
ein womöglich behindertes kind auf der
welt bringen oder ist behinderung oder
die potenziale der behinderung der
argumentieren wir jetzt alles tot
ähnlich ist die potenziale der
behinderung gleichsam ein grund jemanden
das lebensrecht abzusprechen
das heißt es geht hier letztlich hat
gesagt und die frage dass selektion gene
welche formen von lehm lassen wir zu und
welche wollen wir eigentlich nicht ja an
dieser an dieser stelle dich ganz kurz
gerne die schwiegermutter zu wort kommen
lassen die schwiegermutter dieser
protagonistin rät nämlich dieser rahel
dazu die schwangerschaft sofort
abzubrechen genau mit diesem argument
bei gesagt wieso wollt ihr euch das
antun sozusagen
schauen wir uns kurz diese position an
wenn man hier sagen würde mein baby
könnte behindert sein würde ich es ab 3
das ist am einfachsten und leichtesten
in so einer situation
man muss es tun wenn auch nur das
kleinste risiko besteht ein behindertes
kind zu haben dass dir und der ganzen
familie das leben ruinieren und alles
zerstören kann
denn ein behindertes kind wird immer
behindert bleiben da kann man machen was
man will
[Musik]
ich finde ein embryo ist kein lebewesen
also darf man es entfernen wenn du mich
fragst ich würde es loswerden und ein
neues baby machen
vielleicht hast du mühe mit der
vorstellung ein lebewesen zu töten
[Musik]
aber ich glaube nicht dass es besser ist
ein behindertes kind zur welt zu bringen
du hast viele ärzte konsultiert nicht
nur einen oder zwei kein einziger arzt
hat mir geraten das kind auszutragen
du solltest es so bald wie möglich
abtreiben sofort die hand
[Musik]
frau mag es ist am einfachsten das kind
abzutreiben stehen sie zu dieser haltung
ist glaube ich weit verbreitet ich
glaube dass es schon auch eine schwere
entscheidung ein kind auszutragen mit
man wenn man um eine potenzial i tät
einer behinderung weiß dass ich
faszinierend finde an diesem film ist
eben dieser konflikt jemand was diese
schwiegermutter sagt das ist eine
klassische rabbinische die haltung die
man im talmud findet das kind ist und
wie ich finde es ja gar nicht so eine
schlechte haltung also dass der das baby
hat im prinzip wird im moment
lebensrechtler wo es geboren ist und
vorher ist es sozusagen der motor
untergeordnet und vorher ist es eben
auch weil man eine gesunde in gesunden
nachwuchs will und weil man eben dieses
gebot des fruchtbaren sich mehreren und
die weltbevölkerung so ernst nimmt ist
es eben wichtig auch gesunden nachwuchs
zu produzieren und darum würde ein
großer teil der jüdischen tradition
tatsächlich diese abtreibung sofort
vornehmen das ist auch das sieht man im
heutigen israel und ich finde das so
interessant weil das sozusagen zwei
religiöse haltungen sind die einander
wieder streiten und die christliche
haltung geben viel mehr ist als ein
vergabe und um gnade von gott und dann
müsste man das eben austragen und ich
selber finde natürlich dass es in der
heutigen welt wo meistens wo wir
versuchen doch säkulare argumente zu
finden jenseits dieser religiösen
tradition
das ist eine konflikt geschichte ich
finde dass die eltern tatsächlich ein
recht haben sich auch gegen behinderte
kind wir hin der kinder zu entscheiden
das ist allerdings eine wahnsinnig
schwierige und und mit sehr sehr vielen
inneren konflikten und debatten
einhergehende entscheidung aber wir
setzen dieses recht ja auch medizinisch
voraus sonst würden die ärzte nicht auf
behinderungen untersuchen
ich würde für mich zunächst einmal
festhalten wollen dass angesichts dieser
debatten die wir eben hatten über den
schutzstatus des embryos und die
unterschiedlichen religiösen und
philosophischen positionen man dort
keine verbindliche vorgabe machen sollte
politisch und das also frauen das recht
haben sollten guten gründen selber über
abtreibungen zu entscheiden dann kommen
wir sozusagen in die nächste
diskussionsrunde selektive abtreibung
war so selektive so heißt das dann als
gegenbegriff das heißt das sind die
debatten wo es nicht darum geht ein
bestimmtes baby in zukunft nicht
zu kriegen sondern überhaupt jetzt nicht
schwanger sein zu wollen ohne ansehung
der qualitäten des geschlechts
irgendwelcher merkmale die allermeisten
abtreibung auf der welt 97 oder irgend
sowas sind elektiven abtreibung mein
bauch gehört mir gehen möchte jetzt
nicht schwanger sein
es passt nicht mit diesem mann oder es
passt nicht in mein leben nicht gemacht
haben nicht so viele kinder ich kann
ihnen auch noch mehr zu und geben eine
schwangerschaft das wird abgetrieben es
wird gar nicht erst untersucht das macht
sich nicht fest am kriterium des zu
erwartenden kindes richtig und wer die
liberale position hat in bezug auf die
rechte des embryos der ist bei den
elektrischen abtreibungen der große
mehrheit der debatte nicht der meinung
von trump und fans und jetzt kommen wir
sozusagen zu der frage der selektion und
da kann man aus der tatsache dass man
liberaler ist in bezug auf embryonen
recht noch nicht eins zu eins folgern
dass man deswegen auch behinderte
zukünftige kinder ab treiben darf
sondern es gibt eben da auch noch
zusätzliche argumente
das argument der bescheidenheit etwa
dass wir nicht und anmaßen sollten gott
ins handwerk zu pfuschen auch wenn die
embryonen nicht einzeln schützend wert
werden dass wir eine kultur der hybris
der kontrollfreak teams der
unbescheidenheit der des mangels an
bedingungsloser liebe kultivieren
das ist sozusagen eine weltliche
position in diesen fragen und dann halt
die argumente die die behinderten mit
zum teil vorbringen nämlich dass sie
selber durch solche selektions praktiken
sich diskriminiert oder in ihren ihrer
lebensbejahenden ihren lebens rechten
angegriffen fühlten und sozusagen noch
eins drauf gesetzt dass behinderung
ohnehin nur sozial konstruiert sei und
gesellschaftlich zu ändern und gar nicht
etwas mit der qualität des lebens zu tun
habe und über diese dinge müsste man
jetzt training ist ja genau ist weiß ich
ihre position sieht also ich glaube ist
diskriminierend weil sich ja schon
faktum dass sehr viele frauen den
positiven test haben bezüglich trisomie
21 sich für einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch leiden und dass
es weltweit gesehen in diesen in allen
westlichen ländern in denen solche
selektionsmöglichkeiten angeboten werden
nämlich fruchtwasseruntersuchungen mit
nach frau
abtreibung untersuchungen im reagenzglas
pd präimplantationsdiagnostik und
neuerdings den den nichtinvasiven
bluttests dem man schon in der neunten
zehnten schwangerschaftswoche bevor das
umfeld überhaupt weiß dass man schwanger
ist unter trainer tests zu sein nur die
marke aber unter den hier ganz genau
unter dem bild der diskutiert also mit
diesen möglichkeiten hat man ein
instrument in der hand die anzahl der
trisomie kinder deutlich zu reduzieren
und es werden auch immer weniger geboren
das ist überhaupt gar keine frage und
dass diejenigen menschen die mit den
behinderungen gegen die selektiert wird
das als eine kränkung empfinden ist
verständlich und nachvollziehbar aus
ihrer sicht ich glaube trotzdem nicht
dass es ein argument ist eltern diese
entscheidungsfreiheit zu nehmen
jetzt kommen gleich sehen ihre ich
möchte nur noch quasi empirisch sagen in
der schweiz haben die geburten von
kindern mit trisomie 21 nicht abgenommen
und zwar deswegen nicht weil es einfach
dass das gibt das alter der gebärenden
steigt das heißt es gibt sowieso schon
sehr viel mehr fälle bei denen eine
trisomie 21 vorliegt auch wenn sehr
viele damen abgetrieben werden aber zu
sagen die reale zahl der geburten hat
nicht abgenommen letzten jahren ja
herrlich wie sehen sie das
ich sehe es als wirklich schwieriges
problem
ich glaube ja im gegensatz zu sonst
vielleicht etwas zu optimistisch
modernen denken dass das
konfliktsituationen gibt für menschen
die nicht so aber lösbar sind
das heißt dass ich einfach keine
wirklich für allgemeine allgemeine
verbindliche regeln geben kann
ich sehe auf der einen seite wie sie das
angedeutet haben dass das ganz
wesentliches problem nämlich dass wir
denken die ganze inklusions diskussion
inklusions pädagogik ja sehr sehr
zumindest rhetorisch überzeugung sind
dass behinderung soziales konstrukt ist
und im grunde diese menschen nicht
behindert sondern anders sind und
gleichzeitig haben wir ja jetzt was
schwangerschaft und solche diagnosen
oder solche prognosen betrifft und ganz
ganz enges bild von dem was ist ein
gesunder mensch oder was ist ein
erwartbarer gesunder mensch das heißt
war das jetzt nicht unter einem
religiösen kontext der diskutiert
sondern christus säkularisiert zeigt
sich dass eine kategorie die alles
entscheidende ist nämlich wieder gesund
jetzt wissen wir aus der diskussion an
der vergangenen jahrzehnte jahrhunderte
das natürlich nicht so variables werden
begriff von gesundheit
das heißt also jede vorstellung von
gesundheit ist tatsächlich unglaublich
normativ und schafft dadurch hast du die
hand gewissen druck den solche menschen
solche frauen dann natürlich ausgesetzt
sind und ich würde sagen es gibt
sozusagen tragische konfliktsituationen
wo man nicht sagen kann was jetzt
wirklich das moralisch korrekte richtige
gute wäre das kind jetzt auszutragen
weil das abzutreiben das problem was
damit zusammenhängt ist aber jetzt nicht
nur das individuelle problem dass man
sagen kann es soll dieser menschen noch
seine moralischen vorstellungen
entscheiden sondern es geht natürlich
auch hier um gesellschaftliche fragen es
geht genau um diese sozialen konstrukte
von gesundheit und von normativen
vorgaben denen der einzelne dann zu
unterliegen scheint zumindest und ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob diese dies ist jetzt
diese vorstellung die konzeption wir
müssen schauen das ist nachvollziehbar
dass kinder natürlich gesund auf die
welt kommen soll aber gleichzeitig so zu
sagen dass die möglichkeit dass das
nicht passiert auch damit bestehen
gefertigt werden können klar und dass
das ist gibt natürlich dieses risiko und
es ist schwierig allgemeine antworten zu
finden unter tisch ist die heutige
rechtspraxis ja auch diejenige dass sie
ist eben eigentlich den eltern erlaubt
diese selektion vorzunehmen dass die
aber wie schon simon damals gesagt hatte
in den 60er oder 70er jahren glaube ich
war es ist die debatte um abtreibung im
französischen abgeordnetenhaus liegt das
ist abtreibung ist nichts neues sie tue
so rand rahmen das ist immer ein drama
es sind das sind zur konfliktsituation
also gerade auch wenn es so zu sein um
die frage geht mit was für einer
für ein kind kann ich leben und will ich
leben das sind wir können uns da nicht
auf allgemeine sozusagen normen glaube
ich festlegen ich glaube dass der
gesetzliche rahmen muss eine gewisse
freizügigkeit geben weil man eltern
letztlich auch in diesem intimen takt
des kinder machen es eher nicht
sozusagen die dann wieder zwingen sollte
da bin ich glaube ich fest daran aber
das ist natürlich dann eine sehr
schwierige und auch innerhalb eines
paares das zeigt der film
sehr schön auch eine sehr konfliktreiche
situation sein kann und der film hatte
aber auch wirklich ein sehr schönes ende
hin kommt man gesund auf die welt aber
ich möchte gerne noch einen punkt noch
mal auf neben der mir der mir wirklich
wichtig ist sie haben dieses stichwort
erwähnt der demut das annehmen eines
geschenkes und das ist ja ein argument
michael sandel der amerikanische
philosoph bringt dieses argument macht
das sehr sehr stark ich meine es ist ja
auch so sehr viele kinder die behindert
sind werden behindert aufgrund einer
krankheit oder aufgrund eines unfalls
und die frage ist kultiviert man nicht
eine haltung wir machen mal schön ein
test wenn das kind eine behinderung
haben könnte treibende ab und danach
kriegen wir ein gesundes kind und werden
ihm ein gesundes kind haben und
unterschlägt dass eltern zu werden immer
mit dem sagen wir jetzt mal risiko
verbunden ist dass es unfassbar
schwierig werden wird aber dieses bild
bleibt dass da was sie da gerade
zeichnen nämlich dass jemand der sich
für das abtreiben eines behinderten
embryos entscheidet dass der damit
rechnet lebenslänglich ein gesundes
super baby zu haben und auf krankheit
gar nicht mehr eingestellt hat das ist
natürlich sehr zugespitzt das ist
wirklich das bild der kritiker ich denke
der spagat den wir gehen müssen und
leisten müssen sprang hat kann man nicht
gehen den besteht eben gerade darin dass
wir einerseits liberale spielräume
lassen mit blick darauf dass eltern
unterschiedliche moralische position in
bezug auf embryonen haben
unterschiedliche bilder davon was sie
sich zumuten können und wollen und
unterschiedliche vorstellungen von ihrer
reproduktions freiheit wie das heute so
heißt auf der anderen seite müssen wir
sehen dass wir in unserer gesellschaft
ein klima der mitmenschlichkeit der
inklusion der annahme von unvermeidbaren
krankheiten lassen und dass diejenigen
mitbürger die mit behinderung leben und
von eltern sehenden auges auch
ausgetragen werden in der zukunft dass
die auch eine gute krankenversorgung
haben dass wir nicht aufhören
medikamente und hilfsmittel und
inklusions möglichkeiten aller art für
selbstverständlich zu halten und
vorzuhalten
das ist ein schwieriger spagat ich
glaube liberalismus in dieser frage hat
auch zu sagen hohe moralische folge
kosten und und politische verpflichtung
ich würde hier gerne ich würde hier
gerne einen schnitt machen und einen
schritt weiter gehen zur frage wie wir
eigentlich kinder machen dürfen worüber
wir auch diskutieren wollten jetzt haben
ist an ihm darüber gesprochen ob man
schwangerschaften abbrechen darf und da
kommen wir nachher dann auch gleich noch
mal aufs thema optimierung nämlich
zurück wenn wir darüber sprechen wie man
eigentlich schwanger werden davon welche
kinderwünsche erfüllt werden dürfen sind
hier unter anderem bei der eizellspende
die wird im moment heißt diskutiert in
der schweiz weil es viele politische
lager gibt die sagen wir müssten die
eizellspende zu lassen diese momente in
der schweiz verboten im unterschied zur
samenspende wie stehen sie dazu herr
ließ man als spender sollten wir das
erlauben verlegen
ich glaube es ist wirklich jetzt eine
frage kann man ganz covern die kann man
ja also jetzt nach meinem sozusagen
gerechtigkeitsempfinden er in dem moment
zusammenziehen samenzellen spenden
erlaubt sind finde ich sollten auch
einzelspenden erlaubt sein auch wenn ich
weiß das kann ich jetzt zu sagen nur aus
der literatur beziehen oder aus aus
erfahrungsberichten dass eine
eizellenspende etwas komplizierter
aufwendiger und vor allem auch für die
frau etwas beanspruchen da ist alles
zusammen zu sein die er in zwei minuten
erledigt ist ja also die frage ist ob
das risiko argument 1 1 so richtiges
argument ist dass man hier also diese
diese ungleichbehandlung dieser zwei
spenden formen tatsächlich auch
juristisch argumentieren kann das kann
ich sozusagen schwer schwer beurteilen
aber ich würde es als argument durchaus
gelten lassen und zu lassen aber vom
prinzip her denke ich sind das durchaus
vergleichbare verfahren also ich finde
wenn man wenn man das risiko argument
verbindet mit guter aufklärung und
regularien die verhindern dass es dazu
im einzel markt kommt was nicht
wünschenswert wäre das ist das andere
dann ist dieses risiko argument in
meinen augen wirklich unangemessen
bevormundend ich denke frauen sollten
das
selber entscheiden was sie da machen da
gibt es ja auch möglichkeiten zum
beispiel bei frauen die selber
künstliche befruchtung wählen aus
welchen gründen auch immer dass sie ein
paar zellen mehr so genannte euro
sogenannte einteilen genau also überall
diese feinheiten und politischen
möglichkeiten und medizinischen risiken
muss man dann sozusagen noch mal
nachdenken aber das argument der
kritiker gegen eizellspende ist doch
nicht so sehr glaube ich das risiko für
die einzelspenden sondern es ist die
vision von sozusagen unübersichtlicher
und in normaler werdenden
familienverhältnissen die dadurch
ermöglicht werden weiterhin noch mehr
auf gespaltene mutterschaft als schon
bisher die sie durch ob nicht vielleicht
ganz kurz erklären also das ist weil die
frau die das kind gebärt dann sozusagen
nicht die genetische mutter ist das ist
gespalten und geschafft ganz klar und
damit ermöglicht man
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren ein kind
zu bekommen was sie sonst nicht hätten
haben können wird nochmal
unübersichtlicher oder sogar single
parents und so weiter also es geht
eigentlich mehr um die frage der der
vielfältigkeit von familienverhältnissen
die dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr
familie genannt werden von vielen und
dem argument des kindeswohls das ist
jetzt was anderes als in der
ursprünglichen abtreibungsdebatte der
elektiven abtreibungsdebatte wo das kind
ja nie geboren wird und sein wohl also
nicht eine rolle spielt ist das jetzt
gekehrte weil der selektiven einerseits
und bei diesen unterschiedlichen arten
und weisen wie man kinder kriegen kann
mit weißem material und mit wessen
uterus und so weiter geht es um das
kindeswohl und da würde ich sagen sind
die daten ich sag jetzt mal sehr salopp
die daten die dafür sprechen dass diese
kinder schlechter aufwachsen geschädigte
aufwachsen als wir das verantworten
könnten die sind überhaupt nicht da
sondern es gibt gute gründe zu glauben
dass wir mit dieser vielfalt viel besser
leben können als unsere gesellschaft und
die meinungsführer das zum teil denken
weil sie es nicht gewöhnt sind zweierlei
ich finde dass also ein punkt der mir
noch wichtig wäre bei dieser
legalisierung von einer spende
nebst dem risiko argument es ist ja
immer die frage nach medizinischen
tourismus und ich halte restriktive
regelungen für dann absurd wenn die
touristischen möglichkeiten so groß sind
dass sie dann sozusagen also
sie führen sich von selber ad absurdum
wenn ich einfach so zu mühelos ab einem
gewissen gehalt und einkommen was dann
wieder nicht sozial ist eine
unterscheidung nach spanien fahren kann
und dass also das halte ich für die
denkbar ungünstigste lösung weil es wäre
doch viel besser wenn man so seien
innerhalb einer gesellschaft auch mit
den db mit dem so sein beratungsangebot
und so weiter das seien intern lösen
könnte also wenn man alle die eine
technik in anspruch nehmen wollen ins
ausland schickt und das ist im moment
der fall da das argument geht nicht ganz
durch von numark denn ich meine wenn es
wirklich moralisch falsch wäre
einzelspenden lassen und ihr triftige
gründe hätten dann müsste man eben den
zuckerguss argument zähneknirschend
hinnehmen oder verhindert die auch immer
aber passen kann man ja nur gibt gar
keine guten argumente stützt sozusagen
die die vorstellung dass es eben
moralisch nicht falsch ist und ich
glaube auch dass sie recht haben das ist
vor allem eine ideologische problematik
ist und man sieht das ja dass sehr viele
dieser re produktionstechnologien wenn
sie zugelassen werden immer nur
heterosexuellen verheirateten paaren zu
kommen und zugelassen werden
und das ist sozusagen da ist der letzte
schutzwall wo man noch versucht
sozusagen diese große ordentlichkeit die
dadurch entsteht nämlich auch bei
leihmutterschaft wo man ja plötzlich
sozusagen eine man kann nicht sagen dass
eine leihmutter biologisch mit dem kind
nicht verwandt ist natürlich ist neun
monate in einem guten rufs eine
biologische verwandtschaftsverhältnis
kein genetisch ist aber immerhin also
was ist da passiert
psychologisch das heißt oder mit diesen
drei es gibt ja schon drei genetische
elternschaft kinder also diese kern
transfer technologie den großbritannien
zugelassen wurde also wir haben immer
mehr unübersichtliche verhältnisse wo
kinder tatsächlich auch genetisch mehr
als zwei eltern haben und diese nun
ordentlichkeit der müssen sie uns doch
stellen richtig und zwar nicht indem
dafür der aktions technologien darauf
homosexuellen verheirateten paar und
genauso wie wenn ein anderer philosoph
das spricht von der genetischen
verwirrung der kinder die eben überhaupt
nicht mehr nachvollziehen können woher
sie eigentlich kommen nicht das
philosophische ein gutes argument gegen
solche praktiken dass man sagt man ja
wir müssen die genetisch verfolgen
können woher wir kommen
die schule sich unbedingt nach
argumenten gegen solche praktiken
sondern mich faszinierend vielmehr so
sagen erstens die philosophischen
argumentationen die man
prinzipiell hier in anschlag bringen
kann ich halte das tourismus argument
ist ein ganz schlechtes argument der
wären irgendwo auf dieser erde
irgendwelche verbrechen zulässig und wir
in alle das verbrechen begehen wollen
dort hinreißen was man auch tun kann
dann kann man nicht sagen okay dann
lassen wir es gleich hier zu damit ihr
nicht reißen müssen ja also das ist
prinzipiell schlechtes argument
ja aber das ist nur zulässt dass ich
meine man kann dann ja auch unter strafe
stellen wäre denn für villa moralisch
verwerflicher aber so dieses ich hatte
mir das problem vom leibe weil
irgendjemand nimmt mir das stimmt das
ist eine saubere lösungen sind schon
richtig auf der anderen seite auf der
anderen seite denke ich jetzt das von
ihnen genannte argument hängt einfach
davon ab sie haben schon angedeutet wie
wichtig ist tatsächlich das wissen um
seine genetische identität für das was
wir vielleicht ein gutes leben nennen
können das ist manchmal sehr hoch
eingeschätzt worden manchmal ist es gar
nicht eingesetzt worden
also ich bin in einer zeit aufgewachsen
wo wir alle brechts kaukasischem
kreidekreis gelesen und gesehen haben
und was völlig klar war dass soziale
eltern schafften wesentlich wichtiger
sind als biologisch genetische eltern
schafften also aus der perspektive wäre
das für mich überhaupt kein problem
aber ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen
beziehungsweise ich kann mich schon auch
im kind rein versetzen dass man wissen
will wer bin ich
woher komme ich und wir haben auch die
debatte ob man solchen kindern das recht
da vielleicht davon aussprechen
das recht zugestehen soll auskunft zu
bekommen über ihre genetische
zusammensetzung oder ob hier der
schleier des nichtwissens nicht die
besseren lebenschancen
dann eröffnet also für mich ist das
selber noch nicht klar durchdacht und
ich glaube wir haben auch nicht so
wirklich viele erfahrungswerte mit
solchen wirklich dann unübersichtlich
ist und nichts mehr lange da es ja immer
rechts konvention verlangt dass kinder
auskunft erhalten können müssen deswegen
sind auch anonyme samenspende beispiel
sei in der schweiz verboten was ich das
geld elektrische elternschaft er sagt es
ist eben auch sehr kompliziert ich finde
es vollkommen richtig dieser die dieses
recht auf wissen den ländern einzuräumen
mit den gespendeten kindern und also
auch eine spende register einzurichten
wenn man
man so etwas erlaubt schon deswegen weil
wir wissen dass es zigtausende von
adoptierten kindern gibt die snb ist zur
zur ja ich meine das nicht negativ aber
sozusagen zur fixen idee wird ihre woher
sie kommen und schon deswegen sollte man
sagen dass ermöglichen spricht auch gar
nichts dagegen aber nochmal zu dem
kollegen den sie eben genannt haben der
wird wärmer dem geht es ja nicht nur
darum dass eben dass man die genetische
identität kennt sondern es geht ihm
darum dass man möglichst mit genetisch
verwandten personen auf wächst weil man
so meint er sozusagen seine eigene
lebensgeschichte sozusagen im licht von
genetischer verwandtschaft zimmert und
sieht wie man werden könnte mit dieser
cholerischen veranlagung die man vom
vater hat und sich dagegen ab setzt wie
sich dinge durch die familien
durchziehen und so weiter das hat auch
sozusagen eine irgendwie ansprechende
und familien romantischen durch den
tenor
aber es ist eben auch sozusagen das
normale was wir bisher erlebt haben im
idealfall lebt eben ein kind mit zwei
ihm sehr vertrauten menschen zusammen
und bisher war das konventioneller weise
in aller regel was genetisch war man da
eltern zukunft nicht mehr so das muss
nicht so sein also wir wissen ja das ist
liebevollste soziale elternschaft geben
kann und trotzdem wird er vielleicht
zwei gedanken dazu noch also so normal
war das übrigens ist ja nicht wir wissen
die dunkelziffer der kinder die mit dem
finnischen vater heißwachs aber es nicht
wissen hat und das zweite sie wollten
auf eines nur hinweisen müssen wir jetzt
nicht mehr ausführlich diskutieren weil
sie das nur kurz in einem nebensatz
angedeutet und dann auch schnell wieder
ab getan haben ich denke das kann man
nicht so leicht abtun wenn man solche
technologien zulässt egal jetzt unter
welchen philosophische und
gesellschaftspolitischen prämissen man
wird ein es nicht verhindern können dass
es märkte geben wird geo das verhandeln
rühren und und das sozusagen menschen
instrumentalisiert werden müssen um
diese marktbedingungen zu erfüllen ich
halte nichts davon leihmutterschaft zu
romantisieren überhaupt nicht das ist
eine sozusagen degradierung eines
weiblichen körpers zu einem rein
mittel zum zweck schon einen historiker
ist um erschafft erstmal noch draußen
lassen sondern auch zur spende kommt
genau diesen punkt aufnehmen was in der
schweiz in diesem jahr fahren die länder
tschechien und spanien die sozusagen als
tourismusdestinationen gewählt werden
für die entsprechenden frauen die eine
eizellspende erhalten möchten
und man weiß es sind neuere
untersuchungen dass es vor allem
studentinnen sind die so ihr studium
finanzieren
was sagt man dazu das etikett ich habe
erst mal schon ein unangenehmes gefühl
wenn herr littmann das
instrumentalisierung argument hier
anführt so pauschal weil wir alle
natürlich sofort an kants kategorischen
imperativ denken man darf menschen nicht
als bloßes instrument einsetzen
natürlich darf man das nicht aber jemand
der freiwillig blut spendet und dafür 50
d-mark in den 70er jahren kassiert hat
ist bestimmt nicht instrumentalisiert
worden und da ist sozusagen die
einschätzung wann wird man verzweigt und
und zu dingen getrieben die eigentlich
nicht in ordnung sind ist natürlich sehr
graduell und ich finde es auch
schrecklich wenn wenn frauen sich zur
einzelspendern machen müssten bei großen
risiken aus armut gründen aber da gibt's
natürlich auch andere motivation und ich
glaube das könnte man bin ich einfach
optik verhalten optimistischer als er
ließ man das könnte man sicher nicht
missbrauchs festmachen aber doch
irgendwie in eine richtung lenken die
uns besser gefällt also zum beispiel die
idee dass man leihmüttern nur als
leihmütter nur solche akzeptiert die
selber schon kind zur welt gebracht
haben weil sie wissen was da auf sie
zukommt und dass sozusagen sehen darin
august tun finde ich einen winzigen
schritt in die richtung so was
vernünftig zu regeln aber ich bin
überhaupt nicht sagen dass das ein
einfaches da ist ich glaube dass wir
wirklich genau hingucken müssen dass es
keine regeln für jeden fall geben wird
dass wir sozusagen freiräume eingrenzen
müssen und dass das diskussionen sind
für die wir auch übermorgen vielleicht
andere antworten haben als heute was mir
nicht gefällt ist dass man das so sagen
mit totschlagargumenten philosophischer
art erledigt und sagt zum glücklichen
leben gehört es mit genetisch verwandten
zu leben wenn es geht dann aber in der
das hab ich nicht gemeindeleben
entschuldung zwar nicht persönlich
sondern in der sozusagen in der
öffentlichkeit werde neben
embryonenschutz mord und und die
ordentliche familie sozusagen sehr
schnell
als philosophische argumente kassenraum
gewann eigentlich nichts sagen dürfe und
so einfach ist es halt nicht ganz einig
wenn wir von der eizellspende ausgehen
und sagen man sollte die erlauben weiß
natürlich auch bei der frage in welchem
alter sozusagen dürfen frauen denn von
solchen spenden gebrauch machen und da
sind wir bei der frage ob eigentlich
auch frauen nach der menopause noch
mutter werden dürfen
wir sehen hier gianna nannini im bild
das war einer der fälle natürlich breit
diskutiert worden ist sie war 54 jahre
alt dass sie 2010 mutter eines kindes
wurde in der schweiz sind mittlerweile
fälle dokumentiert von frauen die weit
über 60 mütter geworden sind also
eigentlich sagt man im volksmund
großmütter die dann mit verbergen was
ich denn davon zu halten also die
menopause so wie sie für jede frau von
ihrer natur her genetisch und wie auch
immer vorgegeben ist die zum maßstab zu
machen wäre wahnsinnig ungerecht weil
manche frauen mit 36 und andere erst mit
ende 50 ihre natürliche menopause
erreichen das könnte man also nur dann
vertreten wenn man die vorstellungen
hätte das eine ein weiser lenker und
eine wunderbare natur das für jede frau
richtig eingerichtet hat und bei der
einen eben mit 35 schluss sein sollte
und sie keine tauglichen mutter während
bei der anleihen erst später das halte
ich für wirklich quatsch der 65 jährigen
auch zugestehen dass sie noch darauf nun
gar nicht wir können keine altersgrenze
vorschlagen zweite ich will dich ja ich
glaube auch dass man sozusagen dann
einen schritt weiter fragen müsste und
man könnte fragen was sind denn die
gründe die uns so verhalten machen bei
müttern und vätern im übrigen ja genauso
ein fortgeschrittenes alter haben sich
zwei argumente das eine ist dass wir
sorge haben dass betagteren eltern die
energie fehlen könnte
mit mit solchen quirligen kindern
kleinkindern teenagern und so weiter
umzugehen und das zweite argument ist
dass wir sorge haben dass diese eltern
nicht alt genug werden um ihre kinder
bis ins sagen bei junge erwachsenenalter
zu begleiten und diese argumente finde
ich ernst zu nehmen alle beide sind
glaube ich keine gründe für harte
verbote sondern für aufklärung beratung
gespräche mit den einzelnen
und es gibt natürlich auch große
variationen eine frau die wissen dass
sie in terminale krebserkrankungen hat
mit 35 noch schwanger wird und versucht
einen kinderladen nicht jede frau
lehrerin die garantie dass sie die
kinder totale 55 jährige sie sagt ich
traue mir das zu und mein letztes kind
habe ich vor drei jahren gekriegt also
ich wäre vorsichtig mit strikten grenzen
und übrigens spricht ja auch die
bisherige erfahrung nicht dafür dass das
irgendwie die regel werden wird immer
sind also ich glaube auch nicht dass wir
hier mit der normalen so cent
durchschnittlichen common sense oder
vernunft eigentlich hin kommen hier
fehlt es uns nicht an strengen
regularien also gerade weil die
variation und die bandbreite und die
fälle so unterschiedlich sind also wenn
wir jetzt plötzlich den fall hätten dass
alle über 60 aber über 60 meisten über
60-jährigen wollen keine kinder mehr
haben das muss man auch ganz ernsthaft
sagen also von dem er es ist nicht ein
problem was in dieser größenordnung
auftauchen werden davon sieht man
erzeugt möchten sie noch ein kind
das wäre genau der punkt auf den ich
hinaus weiter ich glaube auch hier
vielleicht wirklich selbst und natürlich
das gerechtigkeitsempfinden für männer
war es doch immer so dass er mit 50 60
70 80 noch kinder zeugen konnten und sie
haben das auch getan und sich nicht den
kopf darüber zerbrochen habt ja und
jetzt die neue heranwachsen sehen und
ich denke wenn das technisch möglich ist
das sozusagen auf das andere geschlecht
anzuwenden ist das prinzip der
gerechtigkeit dass das getan werden so
ort getan werden kann nicht sollte getan
werden kann
allerdings was mich jetzt wieder so
fisch wieder daran interessiert ist dass
natürlich alle diese technologien wie
technik schlechthin natürlich darauf
angelegt ist ehemalige natürlichen
schranken zu überwinden und aus zu denen
ja das ist immer ein freiheitsgewinn ist
überhaupt keine frage ist ein zugewinn
an optionen bedeutet aber natürlich auch
immer auch einen zugewinn an
verantwortung wenn ihr danach entscheide
ich ja jetzt ist nicht das schicksal ist
nicht dazu vor der entscheidet sondern
jetzt entscheide ich aufgrund von
technischen optionen die wir eingeräumt
worden sind und das ist jetzt eben
wiederum nicht nur in ein individuelles
problem sagen sie schon auch ein
gesellschaftspolitisches problem wie man
mit solchen zumutungen an den einzelnen
umgeht und es gibt ja auch die
vielleicht nicht ganz falsche
soziologische theorie dass wir in der so
genannten optionen gesellschaft ohnehin
zunehmend überfordert sind mit all
diesen entscheidungen die heute ein
mensch treffen muss die frühe sozusagen
pathetisch formuliert das schicksal ihm
aus der hand genommen hatte auch was wir
früher gesprochen haben gebe es alle
diese diagnostischen möglichkeiten
während einer schwangerschaft nicht dann
wäre es das schicksal das kind kommt auf
die welt und erst dann seht mal und dann
muss man damit umgehen und das hat
übrigens immer kultur gegeben da nur
behinderte kinder nach der geburt
getötet haben ja weil es eben auch
gesunde kinder wollten dann halt etwas
anderes für barbarischen aber jetzt
haben wir möglichkeiten erst jetzt
stehen wir dem problem schon zu welchem
zeitpunkt direkt ihre ich oder gehe ich
damit um oder will ich noch bei der
party und designer baby da kann man ja
noch einen schritt weiter gehen und
sagen lasst uns jetzt einfach mal diesen
geburten fatalismus wie es lothar tag
genannt hat erweckt kippen wir machen
uns die kinder so wie es uns gefällt
aber das war ja immer schon ein traum
heute schon einen stadtplan staat wollen
wir kinder machen die uns gefallen ich
muss jetzt wirklich ganz ehrlich sagen
ich bin hier wahnsinnig ambivalent und
die stehe auch dazu dass ich hier jetzt
keine eindeutige position habe denn auf
der einen seite erschrecken mich solche
vorstellungen der menschen züchtung
nicht nur wegen der historischen
hintergründe
man kann schon die these vertreten dass
wir auf modernsten technischen niveau im
grunde das realisieren was die nazis
wollten menschen richtung gesunde
blauäugige starke intelligente mensch
das heißt also einerseits erschreckt
mich dass ja und auf der anderen seite
muss ich sagen bin ich zu sehr kind
eines technischen zeit halt das
zeitalters um nicht unglaublich
fasziniert zu sein
von diesen möglichkeiten die uns die
gentechnologie in die hand gibt um uns
dieser frage zu stellen und
philosophisch natürlich unglaublich
brisant weil es natürlich eine normative
frage ist wie soll ein mensch ausschauen
wenn ich tatsächlich noch meinen
vorstellungen machen kann
schon bei der ästhetik deinen außer
nicht ästhetisch auch wenn die
ausstattung und die ausstattung da ganz
klar auf märkten noch ein schritt zurück
gehen ganz ganz kurz bevor wir zu den
sanierungs fragen kommen ob nun ist
ethisch moralisch kognitiv wie auch
immer mir scheint aus dem was sie gerade
beschrieben haben nämlich stichwort
optionen gesellschaft kann man zwei
grundsätzliche schlussfolgerungen ziehen
von denen sich die eine für ganz falsch
und die andere für vertretbar und
richtig halte die erste wäre zu sagen
dieser diese überlastung mit
entscheidungs optionen wie sie durch die
neuen techniken und wahlmöglichkeiten in
unserer gesellschaft gekommen sind die
begrenzten eigentlich die entscheidungs
autonomie die selbstbestimmung der paare
um die es doch eigentlich gehen sollte
deswegen sollten wir das alles verbieten
stichwort sozusagen entscheidungs falle
und dass das ist eine position die von
manchen vertreten wird das halte ich für
falsch
ich glaube dass wir wirklich mit diesem
zumutungen im prinzip umgehen lernen
können aber die zweite strategie ist
eine möglichkeit mit diesem zumutungen
umzugehen ist zu sagen ich möchte mich
dem persönlich nicht aussetzen für mich
soll die geburt eines kindes ein
widerfahren es bleiben
ich möchte das nicht kontrollieren und
ich möchte das annehmen wie es kommt und
ich verzichte auf all diese techniken
und das muss eine geschützte option
bleiben und das wird wahrscheinlich auch
eine ganz häufige option bleiben ich
möchte ganz kurz haben christian lord
eine unsere zuschauer hat uns per e-mail
ein kommentar geschickt und er hat
geschrieben und ich glaube seine
position die viele vertreten wir machen
keine kinder
erzeugen sie doch dass sich die
empirische frage wo wir das noch machen
aber er meint dass er natürlich im sinne
eines appells kinder werden gefälligst
nicht gemacht verloren ja natürlich dass
ich meine ich halte das auch nicht für
wirklich realistisch dass wir im jahre
zukunft babys designern und ich halte
einfach die die fragen den wir jetzt
schon ausgesetzt sind glaube ich ganz
frau schöne seifert nicht durch einen
harten parteien an dem man die
entscheidungen wegnimmt sondern ihr
sozusagen durch so etwas wie eine art
von aufklärerischem einüben darin dass
man eben auch harte entscheidungen
treffen muss und ich glaube es ist
tatsächlich so wir zeugen kinder aber
wir haben etwas mehr schon als frühere
generationen möglichkeiten mit diesem
zeugungsakt
aktiv umzugehen und dieser schwierigkeit
dem der müssen wir uns stellen wir
können natürlich back to the nature und
ganz natürlich dass das ist eine option
die bleibt und ich glaube die bleiben
wird aber das andere ist doch einfach
dieses dass wir uns wirklich diesen
fragen also intensiv aus einstellen
müssen dass wir wirklich ich meine dass
das fängt ja schon mit dem geschlecht an
das ist ja es gibt ja geschlechtliche
selektion auf der welt sehr oft und ich
meine wir müssen uns der frage stellen
sollen wie sollen wir da das halten wir
alle für illegitim aber ich glaube ich
nicht warum er wirklich
also da ist gerade in der schweiz auch
eine große diskussion und den eltern vor
entlassungen
wenn man ohnehin schon irgendwelche
gehen also ich muss jetzt schon
konsequent sein ja wenn wir schon so
liberal sind und das sind die
entscheidungsfähigkeit der bahre oder
oder oder auch nur der zukünftigen
mutter gm und die aus welchen gründen
auch immer religiösen hintergründen
weltanschaulich hintergründen vielleicht
auch nur aus einer laune heraus ja du
nicht mag ja und jeden menschlichen
embryo abtreiben lässt warum nicht der
es ist genauso legitim wie aus anderen
gründen etwas nicht zu wollen oder etwas
zu präferieren also nur schon konsequent
sein wenn man schon so denkt aber dass
es schon noch sozusagen zu dieser zu
dieser frage die die jetzt zuletzt jetzt
sieht man der faden etwas berichten also
ich glaube der faden reißt auch ab weil
ich hier büchereien schiebe es ist
nämlich so wir sind tatsächlich schon
über derzeit eigentlich und ja die
schale auf die doch ganz viel zu
diskutieren
ich schätze mal das war nicht das letzte
mal als sie am stammtisch über
reproduktionsmedizin gesprochen haben es
sind so viele themen sich so viel im
gang
ich danke ihnen sehr für diese
engagierte diskussion wir sind nicht am
ende unserer sendung sondern wie immer
kommen wir noch zu unseren
philosophischen tipps frau schönes
einfach was haben sie mitgebracht mein
tipp ist ein buch eines kollegen johnson
glamour aus großbritannien choosing
children und das ist ein buch genau zum
heutigen thema da geht es also um die
frage der selektiven reproduktion mit
durch abtreibungen durch gentests aber
auch durch genetische veränderungen in
der zukunft
buch ist vor zehn jahren geschrieben
aber keineswegs veraltet stammt von
einem sehr scharfsinnigen und sehr
menschenfreundlichen autor und eignet
sich als lektüre auch sehr gut für nicht
versuchen vielen dank alice land ja alle
reden vom populismus und alle reden das
gleiche nämlich populismus kommt von
rechts und populismus ist von übel das
buch das ich mitgebracht habt ist von
den berliner dramaturgen und theatermann
autor bernd stegemann das gespenst des
populismus eine etwas andere sicht auf
dieses phänomen denn stegemann kennt
nicht nur den rechten populismus erkennt
auch den linken populismus und
vielleicht besonders für die schweiz
interessant erkennt sogar einen
liberalen populismus und er versucht
dieses vermögen des populismus
zurückzuführen auf die dahinter
liegenden tatsächlichen
gesellschaftlichen spannungen sehr
interessant sehr lesenswert sehr
diskussionswürdig aber ich muss auch
eine warnung aussprechen stegemann
argumentiert von einem strick
kapitalismuskritischen standpunkt und
das eine warnung ist bleibt
dahingestellt talisman frauen joachim
meinte pilz abenteuer freiheit von carlo
strenger das ist ein autor den ich sehr
schätze ein israelischer
psychoanalytiker und philosoph
ursprünglich aus basel also ein
schweizer ursprünglich orthodoxer jude
jetzt linksliberaler sehr montierter
kulturkritiker und sein thema ist
eigentlich dass das passt genau zu
unserer diskussion es geht nämlich darum
ob die freiheit so wie wir sie
voraussetzen in unseren westlichen
gesellschaften was das eigentlich
bedeutet sie zu leben also und wir haben
eine romantische vorstellung dass sie
jedem zug kommt und dass wir sie
selbstverständlich haben aber vielleicht
gäbe es auch andere vorstellungen die
treffen glaube ich auf diese debatten
die wir geführt haben dass freiheit auch
so etwas ist wie ein einüben und eine
permanente arbeit weil mit freiheit eben
auch verantwortung einhergeht und das
ist bei ihm immer in diesen
kulturkritischen kontext ob wir
westliche werte gegen angriffe von
religiösen extremisten verteidigen
können sehr klug sehr gut verständlich
geschrieben und ein autor den ich ganz
allgemein sehr empfehlen vielen
herzlichen dank ich empfehle heute kein
buch sondern ein
die website ist das portal philosophie
punkt ch für all diejenigen die sich für
philosophie in der schweiz interessieren
oder für philosophische themen
interessieren hier findet man einen
veranstaltungskalender
man findet buch hinweise man findet
themen dossiers und man findet auch
blogger einträge zu ganz breiten themen
wie beispielsweise warum gehen wir
eigentlich ins kino oder was ist
blödsinn dass hier heute hoffe ich war
kein blödsinn hat mir großen spaß
gemacht mit ihnen ganz ganz herzlichen
dank für das mit diskutieren
danke ihnen ganz herzlichen dank für ihr
interesse der kinderwunsch ist auch
thema in der sternstunde kunst wir
zeigen jetzt das berührende porträt über
die japanische prima ballerina meiko die
sich für ein kind entscheidet und damit
ihre karriere gefährdet nächste woche
wird an diesem tisch wieder gestritten
und zwar über die frage was sie mit
tieren machen dürfen
zu gast ist richard david precht mit
seinem neuen buch tiere denken und wir
fragen sie liebe zuschauerinnen
zuschauer sind tiere denn weniger wert
als menschen und wenn ja warum schreiben
sie uns per mail und philosophie ab srs
punkt ch oder auf facebook und jetzt
wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]